TO MIGRANTS WHO FEARED GANG
VIOLENCE OR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE IN
THEIR HOME COUNTRIES.
IT TURNED OUT THAT THE MAJORITY
OF THOSE APPLICATIONS WERE
FALSE.
MR. ATTORNEY GENERAL JOINS US
TONIGHT.
SO, I WANT TO ASK YOU THIS.
BUT FIRST I HAVE TO ASK YOU
ABOUT A PIECE OF BREAKING NEWS.
CATHERINE HERRIDGE JUST SAID
THAT IN JANUARY OF THIS YEAR,
JANUARY 10, DEPUTY
GENERAL ROSENSTEIN WENT UP AND
MET WITH MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE, HAD A DISPUTE
WITH THEM AND THREATENED THEM
WITH A SUBPOENA OF THEIR EMAILS
AND PHONE RECORDS.
THIS IS WHAT ONE OF THEM SAID
IT, I READ IT AS A NOT SO VEILED
THREAT TO RELEASE FULL
PROSECUTORIAL POWER OF THE STATE
AGAINST US.
THE DOJ BACKGROUND HAS CONFIRMED
THAT SOMETHING LIKE THIS DID
HAPPEN.
WHAT WAS THAT ABOUT?
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT THEY HAVE
CONFIRMED THAT EXACTLY.
IN FACT, THE FBI DIRECTOR, THE
SENIOR EFFECTS COMMITTEE SAY
THAT IS A MISCHARACTERIZATION,
REALLY, OF WHAT OCCURRED.
ALSO, I THINK IT INDICATES THAT
THERE HAS BEEN A BREAKDOWN OF
RELATIONSHIPS, WHEN IN FACT,
SINCE JANUARY, A GREAT DEAL OF
PROGRESS HAS BEEN MADE.
WE UNDERSTAND IN THIS DEPARTMENT
THAT WE ARE ACCOUNTABLE TO
CONGRESS AND WE NEED TO BE
COOPERATIVE WITH THEM, TO
PRODUCE AS MANY DOCUMENTS AS
RATIONALLY, LEGALLY AND PROPERLY
AS CAN BE PRODUCING THEM, AND WE
HAVE MADE DRAMATIC PROGRESS IN
THAT REGARD REALLY.
>> Tucker: DID THE DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL THREATENED TO A
SUBPOENA ON THE EMAIL OR PHONE
RECORDS OF MEMBERS OF THE HOUSE
INTEL COMMITTEE?
I WAS NOT IN THE ROOM AND I
CANNOT SPEAK TO WHAT OCCURRED.
ALL I CAN SAY IS THAT THE
PEOPLE -- THE DIRECTOR OF THE
FBI AT OUR SENIOR ETHICS
ATTORNEY WAS THERE AND OTHERS
AND THEY DID NOT SEE THAT IN THE
SAME FASHION.
>> Tucker: SO AS A FACTUAL
MATTER, YOU DON'T THINK THAT
HAPPENED?
>> I'M CONFIDENT THAT DEPUTY
ROSENSTEIN AFTER 28 YEARS AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE DID
NOT IMPROPERLY THREATEN ANYONE
ON THAT OCCASION.
BUT WE DO BELIEVE THAT WE HAVE
TRIED TO BE COOPERATIVE WITH
THEM AND MADE PROGRESS IN
MONTHS, AS THE MONTHS HAVE GONE
BY.
IN FACT, WE HAVE HAD SOME GOOD
RELATIONSHIPS WITH THE MEMBERS
OF CONGRESS.
IT'S.
>> Tucker: OKAY.
SO YOU HAVE MADE NEWS RECENTLY
BY UNDOING AN OBAMA ERA RULE
ABOUT ASYLUM-SEEKERS.
GIVE US THE OVERVIEW.
I THINK MOST AMERICANS LIKE THE
IDEA THAT THIS CAN BE A HAVEN
FOR PEOPLE SUFFERING AROUND THE
WORLD.
LOTS OF PEOPLE CLAIM ASYLUM,
WHAT DO WE KNOW ABOUT THE
VERACITY OF THEIR CLAIMS?
>> THAT'S A GOOD QUESTION.
SEVEN YEARS AGO, 5,000 PEOPLE
APPLIED FOR ASYLUM CLAIMING A
CREDIBLE FEAR OF BEING AT HOME
IN THEIR HOME COUNTRY, AND THEY
NEEDED TO FLEE THAT COUNTRY.
THAT NUMBER JUMPED TO 94,000 IN
JUST SEVEN YEARS.
IT IS OVERWHELMING OUR SYSTEM.
OVER 80% OF THOSE CLAIMS ARE
BEING DENIED BY THE IMMIGRATION
JUDGES AS BEING NOT MERITORIOUS.
SO IT IS A BIG PROBLEM FOR US.
EACH ONE OF THOSE IS REQUIRING
TRIALS AND FACTUAL DECISIONS BY
OUR JUDGES.
WE ARE GOING TO ADD 100 JUDGES,
AND THAT MAY YET NOT BE ENOUGH
JUDGES TO HANDLE THE CASES.
WE NEED TO GET THE JUDGE IS
BETTER GUIDANCE, GO BACK TO THE
FUNDAMENTAL PRINCIPLES, LAWS AND
RULES OF THE IMMIGRATION AND
NATIONALIZATION ACT.
IF WE DO THAT, THEN WE ARE IN A
POSITION WHERE SOME OF THESE
CASES CAN BE PROMPTLY DECIDED.
WE DO NOT GET TO COME TO AMERICA
IF YOU HAVE A PRIVATE THREAT OR
SOMEONE PERSONALLY ATTACKS YOU.
YOU DO NOT GET TO HAVE ASYLUM
FOR THAT, BASED ON YOUR RACE,
RELIGION OR NATIONALITY, THAT
YOU ARE PART OF SOME SPECIAL
IDENTIFIABLE GROUP THAT HAS BEEN
PERSECUTED IN YOUR HOME COUNTRY.
THAT'S WHAT IT TAKES TO HAVE
ASYLUM AND I THINK IT WILL HELP
US.
AT THE DECISION I MADE, I
BELIEVE IT'S RIGHT LEGALLY AND
I'M TOTALLY CONFIDENT IT'S
CONSISTENT WITH THE INTENT OF
THE DRAFTERS OF THE INA, OUR
LAW.
I BELIEVE IT WILL HELP US MANAGE
OUR CASELOADS BETTER AND GIVE
MORE FOCUS TO THE PEOPLE WHO
DESERVE TO BE GIVEN ASYLUM AND
HELP US ELIMINATE THOSE WHO ARE
NOT WORTHY OF THE ASYLUM.
>> Tucker: WITH OVER 80% OF
THE APPLICATIONS ARE FRAUDULENT,
THERE'S OBVIOUSLY A PROBLEM.
SO THEY HAVE ALSO RECENTLY
WEIGHED IN WITH THE QUESTION OF
SPEECH ON CAMPUS.
WHAT CAN THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE DO TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE'S FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS
ARE PROTECTED?
AND WHY HAS IT TAKEN UNTIL 2018
TO GET THE DOJ INVOLVED?
>> IT'S ONE OF THE BIG
CHALLENGES OF OUR TIME, I HAVE
COME TO BELIEVE, AND IT'S ALMOST
UNBELIEVABLE THAT MAJOR COLLEGES
AND UNIVERSITIES WILL BE TAKEN
ACTION THAT RESTRICTS THE RIGHT
OF FREE SPEECH ON A COLLEGE
CAMPUS.
WE HAVE THE AUTHORITY ON THE LAW
TO FILE A STATEMENT OF INTEREST
IN ONGOING LITIGATION.
SO CASES ARE BEING FILED AGAINST
THE UNIVERSITIES BY STUDENTS WHO
COMPLAIN.
IF WE THINK THE COMPLAINTS ARE
MERITORIOUS, THEN WE CAN FILE A
STATEMENT OF INTEREST JOINING
WITH THEM, AND EXPLAIN WHY WE AT
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE THINK
THESE CONCERNS ARE REAL AND
JUSTIFIED, AND COURT RELIEF IS
APPROPRIATE.
WE HAVE HAD SOME SUCCESS.
WE HAVE HAD TWO CASES WHERE
THERE HAS BEEN A MAJOR CHANGE IN
THE COLLEGE AND UNIVERSITY'S
ACTIONS, AND TWO CASES WHERE THE
JUDGE HAS DISMISSED OR REJECTED
A MOTION TO DISMISS THESE CASES
BY THE UNIVERSITIES, AND
ALLOWING THE TRIAL TO GO
FORWARD.
WE THINK IT IS A VERY IMPORTANT
THING.
STUDENTS SHOULD BE PARTICIPATING
IN ROBUST DEBATE, THEY OUGHT TO
NOT BE INTIMIDATED, THEY OUGHT
TO NOT BE DRIVEN BY POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS, TO WHERE YOU CAN'T
EVEN SPEAK UP IN CLASS OR ON
CAMPUS.
>> Tucker: IT DOES -- WHAT AN